let's see let's go to the nine five one
area code caller from 951 who's there
and where you calling from hi I'm
calling from Southern California
soon to be Washington well okay what's
going on hey I just wanted to call in
and tell you how happy I was that Bernie
is running I mean I just I was just his
the speech coming out I mean it was just
so powerful you know it's just it's hard
not even to you know break up and tear
up overheard you know his message yes so
I'm curious
and it might had and if I wasn't
unemployed I would have been one of
those people who put in for that four
million dollars that he raised you know
I mean that's just yeah the power of
power the people right there you know
and right and you know you surprised
binky's go ahead did you vote for Bernie
in the 2016 primary oh yeah I was a big
Bernie supporter and and I was really
upset when don't worry rigged the
election and right so my question to you
was you know after Bernie was not the
nominee who did you vote for in the
general election what I think well most
of people like me you know held their
nose and voted for Hillary because you
voted her hello oh yeah yeah and you
know I just said there was that despite
the fact that your guy wasn't there cuz
you know yeah you're basically voting
against pure evil Donald Trump you know
I couldn't see you know and you know I
think the third party's a wasted vote so
you know well listen I hope I mean I do
you know the 2020 election with that
perspective because unfortunately not
everybody did and that's one piece of
why we ended up with Donald Trump yeah
but I think I think the public you know
the politicians the the corporate
politicians can ruin it you know and
you know right at the end like you know
basically Lucy with Charlie in the
football you know and pull it away right
at the end you know and I yeah I know I
know you know I and I think if that
happens you know Bernie should run as an
independent
you know because that's you know -
stolen elections in a row and yep I mean
that would give the election to Trump
unfortunately but it's an idea you know
I just I mean he you know it's gonna be
on every corporate Democrat in the in
the entire United States okay thank you
for the clarity she ate it and we will
be following Bernie's campaign very very
closely for sure